here's a guy right here who's got some
issues
oh it's me someone actually pointed this
out you guys made a bet
eight over 18 months ago and the bet has
come
uh let's take a look back uh someone owe
someone money in there
under on the betty white life i'll go
140 but how long do you think she's
gonna live though
i would like how is she now though i'm
not sure
100 i want two to one odds for the next
18 months
97 back nine bro
one of the funniest women out there
funniest people but also one of the
funniest women she had a style of her
own man that's
you know sometimes you get a lot of a
lot of a lot of comedians just trying to
rip off somebody else's style the reason
why any of them i feel like have success
sometimes is because they find their own
style and she had a style all her own
and she still she still will for for the
next 18 months
18 months so i get 18 months over
and so that's beautiful so we're going
140 dollars i want two to one
steal theo's friend in 140
that 18 months was october 5th she died
she she no she stayed alive you said
you took me over you took the over damn
damn
pull up another bet that i pulled up a
bet that i won
right before that one uh you guys had
talked about dustin poirier which you
all oh
you lost that one too uh
so oh yeah it must have been yeah
yeah dustin just came out with a hot
sauce today though also so if you guys
want to
this is called diamond hot sauce i don't
know what it's called but it'll
it's literally the tagline this this
stuff will beat the [ __ ] out of you
oh that's great i like that no i'm
joking that's not it oh damn oh i love
that
steve stevo has a hot sauce and goes
this will make your [ __ ] on fire
oh
hot sauce man of course it's got some
kick and some punch it says
that's creative he fights soon yeah
right
january connor january boy january you
want to bet on that one too
yeah all right let's go double or
nothing then i think
yeah what was the bet for betty 140 all
right you would had to pay him 520 had
she died
i can't believe him during covet time
she's kobe can't be real if it's not
killing that lady oh i know
well she might just be locked down
though she might be one of those people
that didn't leave the house like my dad
i don't think she's like your dad dude
she's like a successful actress
you know i mean your dad seemed like a
cool guy i've seen some images of him
but yeah how old is she now
98. what is this
shout out 98 dude shout out bone thugs
and harmony what else happened to 98.
what was big in 98 can you google that
right now top 10 musical hits of 1998.
and cat i want to say thank you for
entertaining us on that game and even
just giving us the opportunity
hypothetically thank you for having me
the man that you do not need
ray of light jay-z hard knocks
backstreet boys everybody
that was a jammy jam get jiggy with it
oh i loved it
jiggly
too close what was that what was that
like you're making it hard for me
oh yeah there he goes that song is
[Applause]
rubbing your dick on her leg that's what
he's talking about
you actually look like hannah gatsby
heavy on the gatsby too looks like he
had a couple servants against me bro
oh my god
[Laughter]
dude you should do some stunt double
work with her
[Music]
is